we got big news
the metaverse is coming
it's here
microsoft buys activision blizzard for
69 billion dollars in cash can you
imagine having 69 billion uh in cash on
your balance sheet
or being able to part with it and still
be a healthy company
microsoft so i have visited microsoft's
campus uh in redmond have you
no
it's like a city it is massive
uh like microsoft is a mammoth
operation with an army of people
just as far as the eye can see in
buildings whatever building you're in
there's another building whatever campus
you're on there's another campus like it
dominates
that entire
you know area region
there was a time when microsoft once
declared a special dividend and it
literally like increased the size of the
local economy by you know 15 percent
check like everyone just ran and just
like bought a house or whatever like it
was like a one-time like they just said
everyone who owns microsoft stock we're
gonna just like give you
whatever it was
what's the what's the budget in new york
city 100 billion dollars yeah give or
take in that range right yeah so
they essentially bought a company for
70 of the budget in new york city just
for some rel like for some scale here of
how big microsoft is
uh
they're their own country i think um
yeah so they decided to throw down the
tune of whatever 68 69 billion for
activision blizzard and i have direct
experience with activision blizzard uh
do you zach have you played i've played
world of warcraft diablo starcraft call
of duty that's activision in it
i think it is activation i mean
activision is one of the biggest
publishers you can look that up um so
it's called activision blizzard because
they bought blizzard which made the
games i just named
i've played candy crush and i played
call of duty oh they own candy crush oh
yeah um so they own a lot
they're one of the big daddies in
gaming where
uh there were three big ones once upon a
time it was ea
activision and take two which made grand
theft auto
now geez like uh activision blizzard
becoming part of microsoft there's so
much heft i have to say that i loved
this move for microsoft okay that if
you're going to try and compete in the
metaverse owning
maybe the biggest gaming company in
addition to what you already have
with uh xbox um they own halo right yeah
the publisher of halo which they bought
for you know a lower amount it's like i
think 7 billion not not that long ago
um so this is a massive move
it's one of those things where it's like
a singular target it's like there's not
another activision blizzard right you
know the so
i love this move for them it was a 25
premium over what activision's stock was
trading at it reminds me a little bit of
microsoft buying linkedin a while ago
uh for maybe i think it was like 26
billion or something like that yeah um
and linkedin is also a singular property
where like there's not another linkedin
so they said let's do it if you think
about people interacting virtually
gaming's uh
the biggest opportunity
uh something like linkedin like might be
top five though
you know because you're there and you're
you're trying to um access professional
networks and guidance and the rest of it
now what are the downsides of this deal
um what it made me think of is that the
small need not apply at this point you
know i mean like if you imagine video
game publishing as this
like kind of wild westy industry and
then some like new publisher can come
and make a hit game right you can pretty
much toss that out the window it's
like you know it's like who's going to
be able to compete with
the resources of these mega corps or if
you did they'd probably just gobble you
up right like before yeah have you ever
made a real hit like a candy crush or
whatnot yeah then they they'd gobble you
up right a take two just bought zynga as
well so this space is consolidating
quick zynga owned farmville oh yeah
draw with friends and uh in the early
days i was trying to gamify suit up
competitions and zynga was one of the
companies we're having conversations
with
it's hard to i mean we're learning with
remote schools the kids don't have that
yeah you know do you know the big
granddaddy player in the space that a
lot of people might not have heard of
no roblox oh yeah i've heard of them
yeah roadblocks like based up i think
they're a little overvalued now but they
are well they might be the future
they're valued to the moon because who
the heck knows what goes on but i gotta
say
if you use my kids
as any indicator proxy like roblox could
be valued at infinite because like they
that's that that is their metaverse yeah
uh oh wait we should look up roblox's
freaking valuation because that's the
move like well that was i was debating
carl and i were debating like buying
this bad boy 44 billion market cap
trading at 75 bucks can you look at uh
up uh
facebook slash metas market cap 900
billion
yeah so if your
facebook slash meta and you see what's
going on uh like you think you know can
we get 110 billion to get together to
buy roblox or something like that and
you don't have that kind of cash on hand
but you can finance you can do a stock
for stock so i think that's the way this
world is going and so the mega
consolidation
is not a great look uh that there are a
lot of dynamics in tech that end up
guiding you towards a handful of mega
companies
and i made this point of the debate
stage a while ago it's like how many
social networks do you want
like you don't want you want one for
your personal and one for professional
that's it yep no one wants to use bing
yeah how many search engines do you want
one how many navigation apps do you want
one like you just want one thing
and so imagining that you're gonna have
you know seven competitors when that
makes zero sense in a lot of these
industries and that's true the metaverse
too how many metaverses do you wanna log
into
one
like i want to go where the people are
where the things are where the cool
is
um so you're
trying to figure out who actually owns
the metaverse what does it look like
one very significant
uh play would be you know what it is
freaking uh starcraft warcraft
uh candy crush like all that stuff like
microsoft's that
uh another bet which by the way this bet
again according to you know what's going
on in my household roblox would be a
very very
big bet i'm actually going to call it
right right now
facebook buys roblox
or it's going to be a bidding war like
you're getting alphabet buys i was going
to say alphabet or uh or apple uh alpha
oh apple buys roblox i'm saying like
these guys are all gonna compete for it
and
roblox may say
f you i'm gonna be bigger than you
that's like the best hope to dethroning
the big four right so so here here's one
of the problems if you're like the the
roblox of the world you didn't interact
with them right oh no so this is the the
problem actually companies were at large
um so let's say roblox is a public
company which it is
um i don't know if they have those
special zuckerberg provisions where the
founder can say fu to everyone and just
do whatever they want um if they're a
normal public company then you have a
board that has a fiduciary
responsibility to the shareholders to
consider whatever is going to maximize
the value so if uh apple comes in and
says hey roblox here's you know a 30
premium to your current by the way crazy
hyped up overvalued share price um like
uh then the shareholders the the board
members have to consider and take to the
shareholders
uh you know you can't just say if you
were gonna you know keep on kicking ass
um
you know you have to you you have to at
least consider it so i i don't know the
ins and outs of roblox's internal
governance um
but
you know on the flip side of your roblox
and you look at it it's like like are
you going to take over the world maybe
um one of the things that happens to a
lot of companies though is and this is
the activision blizzards rationale for
selling um is that they looked up and
said hey how are we going to be able to
compete ourselves
um at the highest level um to build the
metaverse it's like you know what might
help
a parent company with you know tens of
billions of extra money lying around and
you know like a giant business platform
and a giant this and a giant that um so
if you're roblox you look up and be like
hey you know what might help
like a giant trillion-dollar parent
company with devices in everyone's hands
and like a set-top box and you know in
the form of apple my issue my enhance
like my gut without being i don't think
anyone's technically an expert in the
metaverse is not built yet but my gut
instinct on the metaverse is that the
problem
is someone has to build it and own it
and then we all have to
rent or buy from it right it's
if you're talking about building a whole
new world
uh we're at the you know like explorer
phase right where we're traver
traversing around new areas neither
building like we're finding areas that
if it's planet earth people are finding
new areas claiming them as their own
stealing them and then selling them for
profit right in this world facebook is
going to build
said real estate and then sell them for
profit
and why does facebook get to do that
amazon buys right
one of them's gonna go for roblox for
sure
um
i don't know
if that's a good thing right we all have
to buy from so this again is the concern
and it's been happening in tech for
years and years and years like you just
have this mega consolidation happening
uh trillion dollar companies if i start
a new tech startup in this site i say
hey i'm going to be the next google like
laughed out of the room yeah left out of
the room but if you say hey google is
going to buy me for 100 million great
idea yeah i'm listening i'm listening um
and then by the way if you fail
google buys you for tens of millions
just just for the talent
half the time yes yeah so somebody
worked on one of those yeah you got a
job at google it's like the show silicon
valley where you know like you reach a
certain scale like uh you know it
becomes
arbitrary um you're playing with what
tim o'reilly calls uh super money
um and so
like it's it's almost impossible to
compete with super money that they the
laws of business physics stop applying
uh i'm not i'm a former you know small
private company operator like i'm and
you know this about me i'm like i'm
really acutely attuned to the laws of
business physics you know it's like hey
we gotta like you know
um like uh watch what we spend and try
and grow into it and do all this stuff
but like after you achieve
uh
uh orbit or liftoff then like none of
that stuff applies to you anymore
so a lot it's your point a lot of these
things we use every day are getting
consolidated right into these big tech
companies but they're still like these
small businesses that
google doesn't touch
facebook they don't touch because they
they really can't where it's like your
nail salons and your your barber shops
and your small your law firms and
invest in banking a bit and they still
touch them but go on well yeah but yeah
but you know you can have a small
consulting business or xyz but i'm i'm
assuming in the metaverse it just all
goes through facebook right it just all
goes well it's probably similar where
you can set something up and everything
and then they just take a toll they take
a toll this is a dream this is an
exchange rate man
you had to like exchange living the
dream dollars for like meta bucks or
whatever
[Music]
you